Vamos a sumar 9.087 + 15.31. Te invito a que
pauses el video y lo intentes por tu cuenta.
Supongo que ya lo intentaste por tu cuenta.
Ahora veamos cómo podemos resolverlo. Primero
quiero señalar una cosa: algunos de ustedes puede
que hayan visto todos estos números alineados e
inmediatamente dijeron: "Oye, 7 + 1 son 8, 8
+ 3 son 11, llevamos una, etcétera, etcétera".
Pero si hiciste eso, estarías cometiendo un error,
porque justo aquí podemos ver que estos decimales
no están alineados. Al hacer eso estaría sumando
7 milésimos a 1 centésimo, estarías sumando 0
décimos a 5 unidades, estarías sumando 9 unidades
a 1 decena, porque esencialmente esta de aquí es
una decena. Todas las posiciones estarían en
desorden, por lo tanto, lo que necesitamos
hacer es alinear el punto decimal de modo que los
valores posicionales estén alineados. Por esto,
lo que queremos hacer es alinear las cifras,
entonces podemos escribir 9.087, y queremos
alinear los puntos decimales. Vamos a hacerlo.
Los puntos decimales tienen que coincidir,
así que aquí abajo tendremos 15.31, y espero
que esto también tenga sentido para ti. Esto es
9 punto y algo más 15 punto y algo, por lo tanto,
si sumas 9 a 15 tu resultado será 24 punto y algo,
un poco más, un poco menos, y lo podemos ver
aquí: tenemos 9 + 15. Hemos alineado los valores
posicionales correctos y ahora estamos listos
para sumar. Es buena idea comenzar con el valor
posicional más pequeño, de modo que si tienes
algo extra en cierta posición puedes añadirlo
a la siguiente posición. Entonces aquí tenemos 7
milésimos, estamos en el lugar de los milésimos,
y podrías decir "Bueno, ¿a qué lo sumo?, no hay
milésimos aquí abajo" y tienes razón, no tenemos
milésimos aquí abajo, entonces podemos reescribir
esto como 0 milésimos. Así que 7 milésimos más 0
milésimos son 7 milésimos, 8 centésimos
más 1 centésimo es igual a 9 centésimos,
0 décimos más 3 décimos son 3 décimos, después
pondremos nuestro punto decimal, luego tienes 9
unidades más 5 unidades, son 14 unidades, y, ojo,
14 unidades es lo mismo que 4 unidades y 1 decena,
entonces llevamos ese 1 justo acá, es decir,
14 equivale a 1 decena más 4 unidades, y
finalmente tenemos 1 decena más otra decena son 2
decenas. Entonces obtenemos como resultado 24.397.